hey let's go for us my name is Pippa so
today we're gonna do the what's in your
backpack tag this backpack
I showed this backpack in in one of my
videos and you bros were like where can
I get that so it's actually available
right now if you go to chop beautify
calm sigh shop I love this backpack I
used it everyday and I thought I'd show
you what I keep inside it let's look
inside
I bet this is gonna be so awkward like I
really don't remember what I keep in it
um Gameboy that's some skin batteries I
guess toilet paper roll lotta toilet all
right Oh EDD gang are you doing in there
sorry approach well you better go back
in then sure the award for best gamer
Wow love in law that's a great um don't
know what this is
oh of course it's my cane if I if I need
to go for a walk and my attack on titan
waifu pillow sheet so yeah I think you
get the point it's a very very um
durable backpack and that's Edgar on it
so if you want this backpack I suggest
you do it soon last year they were
insanely popular back-to-school is
coming you need a backpack I'm here for
you alright get the backpack or be a
little [ __ ] for life okay
well that's it for us thank you for
watching we would like if you enjoyed
that was what's in my backpack thank you
for watching and as always see you in
the next video stay us